you've learned how to create branches
and how to keep track of which branches
contain which commits using diagrams now
let's take a look at how to combine
changes from multiple branches into a
single version since the coins branch is
finished
I'd like to incorporate the changes into
the master branch if no changes have
been made to master in the meantime back
when I first started it I could just
update the label to be where I am now
but changes have been made in master so
I'll need to somehow combine the coin
branch with the master branch and create
a single version that contains all the
changes from both it can actually
combine the master branch with the coin
branch automatically which is pretty
impressive to get an idea of how this
works let's look at a simple example
first suppose two people I'll call them
Jake and Rachel are editing two copies
of the same file independently you can
imagine that this is the game j/s file
from the asteroids repository or any
other file really at the beginning of
the day they both start with the same
version of the file during the day each
of them make some changes possibly
adding some lines or removing some lines
at the end of the day Jake's version of
the file contains some lines of content
will refer to them as B D and E now of
course in reality these would be lines
of code or maybe instructions for a
recipe but I'm using letters instead so
that you can focus on how to create a
combined version of the file without
getting bogged down by thinking about
the specific content
similarly Rachel's version contains a
couple of lines a B C and D now Jake and
Rachel want to combine their two files
into a single version with both of their
changes for each line mark whether you
think it should be present in the final
file pic yes if it should definitely be
in the file know if definitely not an
unknown if it's impossible to figure
this out from the information that you
have this is a hard question so don't
worry about getting it right on the
first try just try your best and think
about each line individually